this video is made possible by brilliant
you'll learn more about brilliant later
in today's video but if you would like
to learn more about them right now go to
brilliant dot org forward slash by
graphics you'll also find a link in the
description below it was America's first
and most celebrated Western antihero
it was claimed that he killed 21 men one
for every year of his young life and the
press portrayed him as a ruthless
psychotic while die killer the reality
was that Billy the Kid was none of these
things and in this week's biographic s--
we go in search of the real Billy
there is uncertainty as to the
birthplace of the child who would become
Billie thicket most historians believe
that was the slums of New York City and
the year was 1859 his birth name was
Henry McCarty and he was the son of
Irish immigrants who had come to America
to escape the devastating effects of the
Irish potato famine his mother's name
was Catherine but we know nothing about
his father except that he died when
Henry was an infant when Henry was
around six and his mother joins the
post-civil war Exodus to the west in
search of the better life that had so
far eluded them in the new world they
drained a wagon train and undertook the
arduous journey over the Oregon Trail
they got as far as Indianapolis Indiana
their Carolyn met and married a man by
the name of William Harrison Antrim
Antrim had dreams of striking a rich and
gold mines to the southwest and soon the
makeshift family had relocated to Silver
City New Mexico New Mexico in the early
1870s was like a foreign country to
immigrants from the east it was mainly
peopled by Mexicans and Native Americans
the entire culture and religion was very
different to what most Americans were
used to French Spanish and Navarro were
more likely to be spoken than English
and most houses were mesas carved into
the sides of rock formations in this
hodgepodge of cultures violence was
commonplace while many newcomers from
the East would have recoiled at such an
environment young Henry McCarty he
embraced it he immersed himself in the
Mexican culture spending most of his
time in the Hispanic part of town by the
time he was a teenager he could speak
fluent Spanish and could even pass for a
native Mexican with his sombrero and
poncho whenever there was a public
Mexican social event Henry would be
there often with his mother the two
would dance the Fandango together and
talk easily with the Mexican elders
unlike most of the Europeans in town
Henry showed respect to the locals
exhibiting a formal politeness to the
older generation which won him a lot of
praise he was remembered by the Hispanic
community as a charming boy who was
always happy
[Music]
[Applause]
the humor was cruelly snatched from
Henry's life when at the age of 15 he
suffered the loss of his mother
Catherine had been suffering from
tuberculosis for some time it was hoped
that the dry air of New Mexico would
improve her condition but it wasn't to
be Catherine died in 1874 leaving Henry
in the possession of his stepfather
William Antrim Andrew however had no
intention of being tied down with a
teenage boys look after he promptly
abandoned Henry leaving town in search
of more fertile gold diggings so at the
age of 15
Henry was left on his own to fend for
himself in a dangerous frontier town
Henry now had to live off his wits he
spent his time hanging around the
saloons and prostitutes on the serious
side of town sleeping in back alleys and
boarding houses and running errands to
pay his way he soon became involved in
minor criminal activity meeting up with
a hoodlum by the name of sombrero Jack
Henry was recruited as a lookout while
Jack robbed local businesses one of them
was the local Chinese Laundry things
fell apart when a loaded revolver that
Jack had stolen from the laundry was
found in Henry's possession boy was
arrested and thrown into the local jail
it was while sitting in that tiny jail
cell that Henry made a fateful decision
he could have sat and waited for the
circuit judge to come to town and try
his case but that may have taken months
instead he decided to escape
in doing so he honed a skill that would
serve him to good effect many times over
the next five years that was getting
people to underestimate his abilities
Henry talked his garden to allowing him
to come out of his cell for a short
period in order to stretch his legs he
was still confined to the jailhouse and
the door to the outside world was
securely locked but there was also a
chimney when his guard was out of the
room Henry managed to squeeze his slide
frame up the soot covered escape hole
and onto the roof and then into the town
plaza by the time it was discovered that
he had escaped he was free of self a
city and enroute to Arizona carrying no
food supplies and without a horse
Henry displayed an incredible physical
and mental strength in crossing the
desert plains of the southwest he
quickly learned that he had to live off
the land foraging where he could and
stealing where he must the
sixteen-year-old wanted fugitive made it
across 500 miles of deserts before
stumbling into a remote army outpost in
eastern Arizona called Camp Grant's here
he managed to find employment as a cook
on a local ranch after hours he drifted
to the local town where he took the
gambling and hustling in the saloons the
men he was now associated with included
some hardened criminals and they quickly
showed in the ropes before long he was
participating in stealing horses
outside of his ranch duties and his
nefarious nighttime activities young
Henry found the time to perfect his
skills with a firearm he had managed via
revolver and quickly discovered an
innate ability to wield it with this
skill came instant respect from those
around him within a year of escaping the
jail cell in Silver City
Henry had developed into a character of
note among thugs in the Arizona
Territory he wore a brightly colored
scarf around his neck and walked with
the self-assuredness of a man many years
older than his only seventeen years and
it was at this time that people began to
call him the kid it was August the 17th
1877 when the kid went from small-time
crook to hardened killer the local
blacksmith was a bully by the name of
Frank Cahill on that night while
drinking in a saloon Cahill had his
sights set on Henry and he was throwing
insults at the kid when the kid called
him F son of a bitch Cahill jumped him
and proceeded to pound him on the saloon
floor pins underneath the bigger man the
kid managed to free his six-shooter
he shot Cahill in the stomach and then
quickly slid out from under him leaving
the blacksmith to die he hightailed it
out of town on the stolen horse and
headed back to New Mexico now I wanted
fugitive for the crime of murder the kid
changed his name to William H bonny he
wandered across the vast open spaces
relying on the hospitality of Hispanic
ranchers to provide him with a meal or a
place to lay his head
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile New Mexico was being targeted
by Big Shot land speculators from back
east they saw the mostly barren
territory is a golden opportunity for
speculation and they began buying up
land parcels from Hispanic settlers
usually a prices that were manifestly
unfair to the seller those who didn't
want to sell their lands likely we're
going to find themselves facing violent
persecution soon the eastern
entrepreneurs had wrested control of
every industry in the state from mining
to the cattle industry and even the
railroads the largest county in New
Mexico was Lincoln which covered nearly
1/5 of the entire territory it was there
in 1878 that a war broke out that would
have a profound effect on the remaining
years of beneath the kids life in the
late 1860's a couple of Irish immigrants
by the names of Lawrence Murphy and
James Dolan had bought up the majority
of Lincoln County and turned it into a
huge cattle ranch they had secured
extremely large military contracts to
supply beef to Fort Stanton the Murphy
Dolan monopoly in Lincoln County was
called of the house and it was fiercely
protected by a band of thugs known as
the seven rivers gang they operated from
a huge wooden building in the middle of
the Lincoln Township and controlled
every business in town in 1877 the House
monopoly over Lincoln County was
challenged first in court and then on
the range by a Scottish born local
attorney by the name of Alexander
McSween teaming up with the law is a 23
year old recently arrived British
aristocrat by the name of John Tunstall
with a seemingly unending supply of
funds to install was intense on creating
his own cattle Empire in the county in
this quest he enjoyed the support of the
most successful and famous cattle baron
in the entire country John Chisholm
Tunstall began to recruit employees not
only to work the cattle but also provide
the protection that he knew would be
needed when he came up against the house
William Bonney rode into Lincoln County
in mid 1877 and immediately proceeded to
do what he did best
and that was steel horses in short order
he was coerced and thrown in jail it
just so happens that the man he had been
rustling horses from well that was John
Tunstall when the Englishman confronted
the teenage outlaw he declined to press
charges
instead he offered the kid a job as a
member of the regulator's the team of
cowboys that were his protection squad
Billy he grabbed this offer with both
hands in John Tunstall he had found a
man who would give him a fair break he
later said this of his employer Tunstall
was the only man who treated me like I
was decent and white the kid joins a
group of men older than him as he learns
the work of a cowboy
it was long arduous often back-breaking
work and they slept out with the cattle
on the range for the leaders of the
house Murphy and Dolan the idea of an
upper-crust Englishman moving in on
their territory was unthinkable like the
kids parents they had escaped the famine
back in Ireland and deeply resented the
English over their unwillingness to
provide relief now having found a new
life in the new world where they again
to be plagued by the power and the money
of the English well that's something
that they would never allow to happen
Murphy and Dolan's power extended to
control of the legal system that Lincoln
County operated under they enlisted the
aid of William Brady the corrupt sheriff
to enforce a fake court order that
confiscated all of the horses and cattle
on the Tunstall ranch when Tunstall
received the demands he thought it was
some kind of mistake and proceeded to
ride into town in order to sort things
out on the way then he was met by the
sheriff and a posse of men on their way
to execute the court order still
thinking he could reason with the lawman
to install rode towards the sheriff but
before he got close members of the posse
they shot him dead to add insult to
injury they then shot his horse 10
stalls body was soon found by the men
who worked for him and taken back to his
ranch for burial
Billy was incensed at the cold-blooded
assassination of his boss and he along
with a group of hardcore other employees
made a pact of vengeance against the
house they made a hit list at the top of
which was the sheriff of Lincoln County
William Brady Brady's end came on April
Fool's Day 1878 as he was taking his
morning stroll through Lincoln Billy and
his fellow regulators were lying in
ambush and poured more than a dozen
bullets into his body during the
gunfight that ensued with Brady's
deputies Billy was shot in the thigh
three days later a shootout occurred at
blazes mill this time two of the
regulator's were killed as a result of
the two incidents
murder warrants were issued including
one for Billy the conflicts came to a
head when Alexander McSween rode from
the Tunstall ranch with between 50 and
60 regulators on July the 14th 1868 some
of the men strategically positioned
themselves between buildings and on
rooftops while others including Billy
set themselves up in a house that
belonged to McSween for the next two
days they waited on July the 16th the
new sheriff George Patton sent some men
to kill the regulator's who were
stationed on the roof of the saloon
after one of their number was killed
these men were forced to retreat heaven
now send a message to Fort Stanton
requesting military assistance the
request was initially turned down but
the military brass changed their mind
the next day with that Colonel Nathan
Dudley rode into town at the head of a
troop of soldiers a standoff ensued for
a couple more days then on Friday July
the 19th all hell broke loose the
regulator's were now all holed up in the
McSween house a massive barrage of
firepower was unleashed on this house
with returned fire coming just as
fiercely then the house was set on fire
and then attempted to escape Alexander
McSween was shot dead barely managed to
kill the man who had felled McSween
before making good on his own escape
along with the other regulators now just
before we get into the rest of Billy's
life I do want to take a moment to thank
the people who make this video possible
and that would be brilliance I know a
mid-roll ad is not great for the story
here but these videos are long so I do
hope you appreciate our need to have
sponsors to make them possible brilliant
are a learning platform which teaches
through something called active learning
unlike biographies which have just a
nice way to learn about people's lives
nothing about science it's trickier I
don't know if you've ever had to sit
down with a science textbook I have and
I read them and there's a whole lot of
stuff that makes me think what hold on a
second and then you end up reading the
page six times over and you're still not
taking it in
well brilliant solves that problem with
active learning brilliant give you
something super short to read it's
really easy and then you immediately
apply it to a problem you rinse and
repeat that and suddenly you're
understanding all sorts of stuff that
you really didn't think you'd be able to
I've been using brilliant and you should
just go try it just to see how easy it
is to suddenly be understanding all
these complex subjects it's really
brilliant just making them super easy to
grasp you can support by graphics by
going to brilliant or
/bi graphics and now let's get back to
the kid
[Music]
by now billiard developed into a
seasoned killer he was now wanted for
multiple counts of murder in different
jurisdictions still he was able to find
refuge with the Hispanic sheep herders
who viewed him as a fighter for their
liberty against the Anglo robber barons
the firestorm that had erupted in the
heart of Lincoln County forced
authorities to act indictments were
issued for the arrest of billion two
other regulators for the murder of
Sheriff Brady a new governor of New
Mexico Territory was also appointed the
man given the job was Lew Wallace a
former Union Army General and future
author of the book Ben Hur Wallace set
out for Lincoln County with direct
instructions from President Rutherford B
Hayes to restore order but Wallace
encountered a population who were too
terrified to get involved and so was
unable to secure any witness testimonies
as to what had been occurring then he
received a letter from a man calling
himself William H Bonney the kids
offered to testify against the members
of the house in return for full amnesty
and swalot agreed Lillie testified
before a grand jury with his testimony
leading to indictments against a number
of House members including leader James
Donen then he had lived up to his side
of the deal but unfortunately the
governor did not live up to his skipping
town before the amnesty he could be
formalized
with the governor gone most of the
indictments against the House members
they were dropped but those against the
regulator's they remained Billy fled
town before he could be arrested while
the other regulars fled in New Mexico
Territory Billy decided to stay put and
eke out a living as a cattle and horse
Rustler over the next few months he
harassed the ranchers of the house
Empire in the process becoming the most
wanted man in New Mexico the newspapers
of New Mexico most of which were simply
mouthpieces for the House demonized the
kid blaming him for every misdeed in the
territory in 1880 the editor of the Las
Vegas Gazette first names the outlaw
Billy the Kid the name for which he
would forever be known
[Music]
[Applause]
by the summer of 1882 he still roams the
territory Billie had made a base for
himself at Fort Sumner some hundred
miles from Lincoln by now Lincoln had a
new sheriff and his name was Pat Garrett
and he was single-minded with his
obsession to capture Billy the Kid
Garrett was a tenacious determined man
he and his posse tracked Billy and his
gang over the winter of 1880 two of the
outlaws were killed in a shootout with
the others being cornered in a cabin at
a place called stinking Springs after a
tense standoff Billy finally came out
with his hands in the air
the kid was transported by train to
Santa Fay and put on trial for the
murder of Sheriff
Brady he was found guilty and sentenced
to death by hanging the next and
supposedly last stop was Lincoln where
he was held in a second-story room of
the Lincoln County Courthouse it was
there that he was to wait for his date
with the noose but well Billy he had
other plans on April the 28th 1881 in
the early afternoon Billy told his guard
that he needed to use the Privy the
guard escorted him in shackles to the
outhouse on the way back as he went up
the stairs to his room but he managed to
slip out of his hand shackles he turns
and wrestled with the guards managing to
grab his gun the man turned to flee but
Billy shot him dead the kid then made
for one of the rooms in which he knew
there was a shotgun quickly loading it
he ran to a window and looked down on
the street to see another guard Bob
Olinger who had been eating his lunch
across the way come running to
investigate Billy called out hello Bob
before blasting him with both barrels
with both guards dead Billy then raced
downstairs he commandeered a horse and
was away Billy's daring escape made him
the most famous outlaw in the country
but it also made him a three-time cop
killer this changed Pat Garrett's mind
now he wanted to hunt him down and kill
him despite this and he chose to remain
in New Mexico the reason being is that
he had fallen in love with a 16 year old
girl by the name of Polly to Maxwell
back in Lincoln Garrett was receiving
information as to the whereabouts of the
kid they were being supplied by the
older brother of Polly two-piece Maxwell
who was not happy about this romance
he told Garrett that Billy was in Fort
Sumner Garrett finally moved on the
intelligence he stole into Fort Sumner
on the evening of July the 14th 1881
with two deputies alongside him they
went straight to the home of the max
posting the due deputies on the front
porch she'd been to the house from the
back and made for the bedroom of Pete
Maxwell at this very moment Billy was
approaching the porch in the dark he
could only just make out the shape of
the two men there and he called out who
is it but there was no reply at this
Billy cautiously backed through the open
doorway inside Garret and Maxwell were
sitting on the bed on seeing the figure
Maxwell leaned over and whispered it's
him
Garrett leveled his six-shooter and
fired Billy the Kid fell dead never
knowing who had fired the fatal bullet
so I really hope you found their video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe brand new videos just like
this two times a week or so do check out
brilliance you'll find a link to them in
the description below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]